harte wochen für deutschland ärger
vieler mahnt die kontakte über
weihnachten zu reduzieren und nicht zu
reisen
milliardenschwere hoffnung in den usa
einigen sich demokraten und republikaner
auf ein gigantisches corona hilfspaket
plädoyer im mordfall lücke die
bundesanwaltschaft fordert lebenslange
haft für den hauptangeklagten
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen guten abend
und vielen dank dass sie bei uns sind
den sportlichen nachrichten dienstag hat
christian im blick so ist es genannt
es werden harte wochen die vor uns
liegen darauf hat die deutschen heute
der chef des robert koch-instituts
eingeschworen
so lange werde es dauern bis die zahl
der schwer kranken und toten durch
corinna zurückgehe
die in großbritannien aufgetreten die
mutation des virus sei mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit auch bereits bei uns
die experten wiederholen ihren appell
kontakte vermeiden
auch die impfung bringe keine rasche
lösung
christina kaiser jetzt mit dem überblick
sie stehen hier in regensburg schlange
für einen corona test sie wollen sicher
gehen damit das weihnachtsfest mit der
familie nicht zum viren hotspot wird
ich muss mich testen lassen weil ich
einen negativen test brache sonst kann
ich meine mutter aus dem pflegeheim
nicht holen
bayern führt ab morgen eine testpflicht
für reise rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
ein quarantäne reicht dann nicht mehr
die reisen und die feiertage bereiten
auch dem chef des robert-koch-instituts
große sorgen
er richtet einen drastischen appell an
die bevölkerung bitte schränken sie ihre
kontakte auf das nötigste ein verreisen
sie nicht treffen sie möglichst nur
wenige und wenn dann nur immer dieselben
menschen
er verweist auf die steigenden
sterbezahlen und 380 corona tote im
oktober im dezember sind es bereits über
3.000 jeden tag werden es zudem mehr
patienten auf den intensivstationen
aktuell sind 20.000 268 intensivbetten
mit erwachsenen belegt 3823 plätze sind
nur noch frei wir hoffen im moment dass
die menschen auch über weihnachten
gerade auch wenn das das fest der liebe
ist tatsächlich sich auf eine minimale
kontakte beschränkt weil wir wirklich
sorge haben dass dann wieder 10 14 tage
später nochmals ein schon kommt alle
hoffen auf die impfung wie hier in
berlin stehen die mobilen impf teams
bereit sie starten am 27
in den heimen
die zahlen werden sich damit kurzfristig
aber nicht ändern betont auch der
bankchef
das virus wird bleiben auch in den
nächsten zehn jahren wir werden uns
daran gewöhnen müssen dass es
infektionen und kleinere ausbrüche geben
wird immer und immer wieder durch den
impfstoff bekomme man die pandemie wohl
erst bis zum ende des sommers in den
griff und so helfen derzeit nur die
kontakt beschränkungen um die
ausbreitung und die mutation des virus
einzudämmen
das robert koch institut meldet aufgrund
von positiv testungen 19 1528
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
es gibt einen neuen höchstwert seit
beginn der pandemie bundesweit liegt die
sieben tage incidents bei knapp 200 und
besonders schlimm ist die lage in
sachsen dort gab es in den letzten
sieben tagen im schnitt 427 neue corona
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner aus dresden
berichtet cornelia schiemenz sie
arbeiten sieben tage rund um die uhr
vier schicht system im krematorium
meißen die über sterblichkeit in sachsen
ist enorm
46 prozent mehr tote als im mittel der
letzten jahre der grund corona die
eingepackten tages in die qualifizierten
verstorbenen bei uns die folie gibt
natürlich eine entsprechende sicherheit
der hier
man kann kaum noch in kontakt kommen
die krematorien in sachsen arbeiten
inzwischen an ihren kapazitätsgrenzen
rund die hälfte der särge hat einen
corona warnaufkleber hochinfektiös
dreimal in 30 minuten mahnt der
ministerpräsident heute vor den sachsen
liegen die zehn härtesten wochen
es wird eine grippewelle geben
die frage ist wie hoch sie ist und die
sorge von allen die sich mit diesem
thema beschäftigen ist dass sie sich
auftürmt auf dem jetzt schon sehr hohem
niveau
die neue infektionszahlen stagnieren auf
diesem sehr hohem niveau
erklärungsversuche in meißen sie sind
sich nicht einig keine klare regelung
ist ja schon niemand mehr unterwegs die
die leute stecken sich in den familien
gibt einige menschen die sich wirklich
daran halten und dann geht's halt viele
menschen die halt ihre theorien
aufstellen sagen corona gibt es nicht
doch im krematorium sehen sie jeden tag
mehr särge mit corona toten auch
weihnachten werden sie deshalb durch
arbeiten
die bundesregierung hat den reiseverkehr
aus großbritannien und südafrika weiter
eingeschränkt grund ist die dort
aufgetauchte corona virus mutation
transportunternehmen dürfen passagiere
nicht mehr befördern egal ob per
flugzeug schiff bus oder bahn
das verbot gilt vorerst bis zum 6 januar
gegen pauschale reiseverbote hat sich
die eu-kommission ausgesprochen es müsse
ausnahmen für heim reisende geben
auch der frachtverkehr müsse
sichergestellt werden in dover in
südengland stauen sich die lastwagen
inzwischen kilometer weit weihnachten im
krankenhaus das wünscht sich niemand in
diesem jahr wird das noch einmal ganz
besonders klar
und dann gibt es die die weihnachten aus
beruflichen gründen im krankenhaus
verbringen weil sie als ärztinnen oder
pfleger ihre patienten nicht allein
lassen können egal was der kalender sagt
nicola albrecht zeigt weihnachten 2020
im klinikum niederlausitz in brandenburg
wo es gleich drei kowitz stationen gibt
es ist einzig der dezente adventsschmuck
auf der intensivstation im klinikum
niederlausitz der hier daran erinnert
dass bald weihnachten ist
doch dafür hat pflegerin petra kittel in
diesem jahr kein auge intensivstationen
und weihnachten ist ja immer schwierig
menschen kämpfen hier ums überleben
während wir zu hause sitzen bei
bescherung und gänsebraten und diesem
jahr ist das anders weil ohne luft zu
holen
schon seit november in einer
angespannten situation arbeiten
angespannt bedeutet dauerdienst am limit
und weil auch an weihnachten besucher
verboten sind versuchen sie video chats
zwischen patienten und angehörigen zu
ermöglichen filmen dürfen wir das nicht
auch wegen der ansteckungsgefahr von den
ärzten und pflegerinnen mit denen wir
zuvor bei dreharbeiten gesprochen hatten
haben sich inzwischen einige selbst
infiziert insgesamt sind nun 75
mitarbeiter positiv
es ist natürlich auch für meine familie
weihnachtszeit für meine familie sieht
mich jeden früh gehen werden sie zu
hause sitzen
ich komme ja und wenn ich zu meinem test
gehen muss man habe ich als allererstes
die viertelstunde angst dass der test
vielleicht auch positiv sein wird an den
festtagen frei nehmen können sich die
wenigsten für die kinder des
klinikpersonals haben sie in der derzeit
geschlossenen tagesklinik eine
notbetreuung eingerichtet therapeutisch
geschultes personal wird sich um sie
kümmern erklärt uns bei bet kaufmann
es gibt vielleicht auch kinder die in
der schwerer fällt und wir wollen den
kindern diesen großen namen zustand so
angenehm wie möglich machen
pizza backen heißt es dann zum beispiel
für die kleinen an den feiertagen
während mama oder papa am baum vorbei
zum patienten ein
[Musik]
der test vor dem fest viele wollen sich
vor weihnachten noch testen lassen darum
geht es gleich bei zdf heute live sie
können einem virologen ihre fragen
stellen ab 19 30 auf zdf heute und in
unserer app und dort finden sie
jederzeit auch alle zahlen zum stand der
pandemie im überblick so jetzt gucken
wir in die usa die nach absoluten zahlen
weiterhin das am schwersten von corona
betroffene land der welt sind
monatelang haben republikaner und
demokraten gerungen und jetzt haben sie
sich auf einen 900 milliarden dollar
schweres paket geeinigt dass die
wirtschaft ankurbeln soll
insbesondere der schwächeln der
arbeitsmarkt bereitet dort fielen sorgen
auch dem designierten präsidenten joe
biden
der hat sich jetzt
öffentlichkeitswirksam impfen lassen und
ruft seine landsleute auf es ihm
nachzumachen aus washington britta jäger
bis in die dunkelheit hinein steht rosa
ostsee oder in der schlange hier in
montgomery county maryland teilt eine
hilfsorganisation lebensmittel aus die
pandemie hat rosa und ihren mann
arbeitslos gemacht ohne die spende
könnte sich die siebenköpfige familie
nicht über wasser halten
wenn leute sagen dies sei das reichste
land der welt dann vergessen sie uns die
familien mit geringem einkommen die
reichen familien haben geld aber uns
lässt man jeden tag kämpfen
monat für monat wurden die schlangen vor
den tafeln immer länger bei rund 50
millionen amerikanern war das essen
knapp darunter 15 millionen kinder mit
dem geschnürten hilfspaket sollen
bedürftige nun einmalig 600 dollar
erhalten
außerdem gibt es weitere
arbeitslosenunterstützung 300 dollar pro
woche eine erste linderung für die
demokraten im kongress aber zu wenig um
die wirtschaftliche not langfristig zu
bekämpfen
das ist ein guter beschluss heute ist
ein guter tag aber das ist noch nicht
das ende das kann nicht das ende sein
jeder der denkt dieses hilfspaket sei
ausreichend der weiß nicht was in
amerika los für viele kleinunternehmer
und selbstständige kommt die hilfe zu
spät die politik hat zu lange gestritten
die helfer in montgomery county stellen
sich darauf ein dass ihre arbeit
weitergeht
ich denke die menschen werden lange
brauchen um sich davon zu erholen manche
sind seit neun monaten oder einem jahr
ohne arbeit und die rechnungen kommen
weiter helfer und bedürftige hoffen nun
dass es eine weitere finanzspritze geben
wird wenn der neue präsident im amt ist
im fall des vergifteten kreml kritikers
alexej nawalny wird der ton rauer
russland hat jetzt einreiseverbote gegen
vertreter von eu staaten verhängt
darunter auch gegen deutschland russland
sagt es antwortet damit auf sanktionen
die die eu nach der gift attacke gegen
russische funktionäre verhängt hatte
navalny hatte gestern für aufsehen
gesorgt als er den mitschnitt eines
brisanten telefonats veröffentlichte
dort spricht er nach eigenen angaben mit
einem der agenten die ihn töten sollten
der mann gibt in dem gespräch das
attentat zu der russische geheimdienst
bezeichnet den mitschnitt als fälschung
im mordfall walter lübke fordert die
bundesanwaltschaft eine lebenslange
freiheitsstrafe für den hauptangeklagten
in ihrem plädoyer blieb sie heute dabei
dass stefan ernst den früheren kasseler
regierungspräsidenten allein tötete
lübke sei wegen seines einsatzes für
flüchtlinge zum anschlagsziel geworden
ob der ebenfalls angeklagte markus h
auch bei der tat dabei war ist vor
gericht weiter umstritten
mehr von susanna santina
auch nach dem prozesstag heute bleibt
der mitangeklagte markus hau freiem fuß
wegen fluchtgefahr hatte die
bundesanwaltschaft haftbefehl beantragt
nachdem sie für markus h wegen beihilfe
zum mord mehr als neun jahre haft
gefordert hatte
stefan ernst soll lebenslang hinter
gittern mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung und der
feststellung der besonderen schwere der
schuld und bei der vielzahl der
straftaten über die wir hier beim
angeklagten ernst regen und der
konkreten tatbegehung und dieser
gewaltspirale die sich da seit seinem
jugendalter bei und durchgezogen hat
nehmen wir eben solche besonderen
umstände an
nach ansicht der bundesanwaltschaft hat
stefan ernst alleine den politiker
walter lübke am ersten juni 2009 10
ermordet auf seiner terrasse in
wolfhagen ist da markus h soll aber für
den mord vorsätzliche hilfe geleistet
haben unter anderem weil er mit ernst
schießen geübt und die ihnen der
ablehnung von walter lübke bestärkt habe
weil der lücke familie glaubt nach wie
vor an eine mittäterschaft von marcus h
die familie ist auch aufgrund des
schlüssigen geständnisses von stefan
ernst der festen überzeugung dass marcus
h in dieser nacht mit am tatort war mit
an dieser tat beteiligt gewesen ist
eindringlich sprach die
bundesanwaltschaft heute davon dass
weiter lübke wegen seiner überzeugung
zum anschlagsziel wurde stellvertretend
für die deutsche politik das urteil für
markus h und stefan ernst soll am 26
januar fallen
beim thema rundfunkbeitrag hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht vor wenigen
minuten eine eil entscheidung getroffen
darin lehnen die verfassungsrichter den
erlass einer einstweiligen anordnung zum
rundfunkbeitrag ab ard zdf und
deutschlandradio hatten vor einer woche
in karlsruhe geklagt nachdem sachsen
anhalt die erhöhung des rundfunkbeitrags
um 86 cent blockiert hatte wir fragen
nach bei felix zimmermann aus unserer
rechts redaktion felix guten abend
zunächst mal wie begründete das gericht
die entscheidung jetzt das war ja ein
eilverfahren jeder bürger hat ja immer
das recht zu wählen mache ich an
altverfahren oder ein
hauptsacheverfahren und beifang kommt es
darauf an drohen jetzt sofortige
unmittelbare nachteile
und die hat hier das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht gesehen
die sendeanstalten hätten nicht
hinreichend dargelegt warum jetzt sofort
diese erhöhung in kraft treten müssen
die hätten mit einer deckung problematik
2022 2024 argumentiert und warum jetzt
sofort der beitrag erhöht werden müsse
sei eben nicht plausibel dargelegt
worden okay also die dringlichkeit sehen
die richter nicht aber dann stellt sich
natürlich gleich die zweite frage hat
das auch inhaltlich jetzt schon
eventuell etwa auswirkungen auf das
hauptverfahren also kann man da was
erkennen in der entscheidung heute für
das hauptverfahren
nein überhaupt nicht das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat darauf
hingewiesen dass hier aufgrund der
bisherigen rechtsprechung eine
verletzung der rundfunkfreiheit der
anstalten sehr wohl möglich ist und es
hat auch gesagt zwar ist jetzt die das
staatsvertrag erst einmal hinfällig aber
das bundesverfassungsgericht ist nicht
daran gehindert durch eine spätere
hauptsache entscheidung diesen vertrag
in kraft zu setzen
und was jetzt die gebühren angeht bis zu
dem zeitpunkt nicht bezahlt werden
müssen ist es durchaus möglich dass eine
wie auch immer geartete mehr
kompensation für die sender dann in
betracht kommt also keine sache
entscheidung in der hauptsache sagt
felix zimmermann aus unserer rechts
redaktion danke für diese erläuterungen
heute abend ganz anderes thema jetzt
noch anfang september zerstörte ein
feuer im flüchtlingslager moria auf
lesbos die unterkünfte von rund 13.000
menschen
hilfsorganisationen hatten die zustände
dort in den monaten davor scharf
kritisiert das bild von mehreren kindern
auf der flucht vor den flammen wurde
jetzt das unicef
des jahres ist zeige tapferkeit
fassungslosigkeit und hilfsbereitschaft
von kindern
angesichts von not und gefahr sagt das
kinderhilfswerk
auf platz zwei kommt ein bild von zwei
mädchen die in einer indischen kohlemine
schuften müssen
und der dritte preis geht an ein foto
von ballettschülerinnen in einem
armenviertel von rio de janeiro ein
moment der unbeschwertheit in einer
bedrückenden umgebung drei fotos dieses
jahres jetzt der sport und kristin otto
genau und einer tradition um weihnachten
darts wm in london ein riesenspektakel
allerdings diesmal nun doch ohne
zuschauer im legendären alexandra palace
und mit einer premiere einem deutschen
duell das gabriel clemens in runde zwei
gegen nico kurz für sich entschieden hat
so ein deutsches duell im stadtpalast
ally pally das ist noch etwas ganz
besonderes gabriel clemens besiegt nico
kurz in einem wahren krimi
ich bin gerade sehr glücklich auf die
dritte runde
dem erst 23-jährigen nico kurz gelingen
immer wieder nerven starke abschlüsse
wie dieser 161 er
so setzt er clemens unter druck doch der
zeigt sein bestes spiel souverän wirft
die 180 ganze sechs mal und gewinnt das
match 3 zu 1 nach sätzen
am 28 12 wartet nun der titelverteidiger
peter roith am tag vor dem
zweitrunden-pokalspiel gegen bochum
haben fußball bundesligist mainz 05 und
sportvorstand rouven schröder ihre
zusammenarbeit vorzeitig beendet als
nachfolger beim tabellenvorletzten ist
ex manager christian heidel im gespräch
neue personalsorgen bei borussia
dortmund der bvb muss am abend auf
seinen stürmer talent mukoko verzichten
der 16 jährige pausiert wegen einer
leichten knieverletzung auch ohne ihnen
will dortmund in braunschweig eine
rechnung begleichen
gerade noch wütend über die niederlage
bei union berlin da wird den bvb profis
auch noch erzählt dass dortmund sowas
auch im pokal
sie ihren kann vor 15 jahren in
braunschweig erlebt ja genau
beim heutigen pokalgegner eintracht
braunschweig den 2 1-siegtreffer
erzielte damals kapitän daniel graf bvb
manager zorc gibt vor sich gar nicht
mehr so recht zu erinnern nun versucht
die zu vergessen ganzen aber ich habe
das jetzt auch gelesen dass wir da schon
mal eine bittere niederlage einstecken
müssen
das gute an der ganzen geschichte ist
ich glaube kein spieler aus der
aktuellen mannschaft war damals dabei
dann müssten sie ja nur noch das 1 2 bei
union aus den köpfen kriegen nur noch
leicht gesagt ja das stimmt hat sich
dank gern so jetzt noch ein paar bilder
bei denen man hängen bleibt im wahrsten
sinne des wortes vom himmel hoch da komm
ich her dachte sich in kalifornien
dieser gleitschirmflieger ich meine
dieser weihnachtsmann
er wollte kindern süßigkeiten bringen
das ging dann nicht ganz glatt kurz nach
dem start hat er sich in stromleitungen
verfangen
großeinsatz für die feuerwehr die hatte
alle hände voll zu tun den
weihnachtsmann wieder zu befreien
mit rentieren wäre ihm das nicht
passiert das wetter weiter regnerisch
und noch mal sehr mild die weihnachts
vorhersage hat gleich gunther tiersch
dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute schon
mal mit der kollegin marietta slomka um
22 uhr
sie hat fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister und wir sehen
uns gerne morgen wieder wenn sie wollen
aber erst ich wünsche ihnen allen ein
sehr angenehmer
[Musik]
gute zuschauer bis zum donnerstag bleibt
es bei uns regnerisch diese milde luft
kommt aus südwesten und sie ist eben
sehr sehr feucht vom atlantik bringt sie
das mit und deshalb wird es morgen und
auch noch am donnerstag viel regnen aber
ist dieses tief durchgezogen dann wird
es ab donnerstag von norden kühler und
das bedeutet es gibt schnee in den
mittelgebirgen heute nacht ist es eben
nur regen genau in der mitte
deutschlands im norden ist es trocken
genauso wie südlich der donau david
allerdings über süddeutschland dieser
kräftige südwestwind und dieser
südwestwind bringt uns dann morgen
wieder dieses milde wetter temperaturen
meist zwischen 11 und 17 grad nur ganz
im norden das ist etwas frischer mit
fünf bis sieben grad ja und insgesamt
wird es ein regnerischer tag vormittags
es regne den besten es regnet in der
mitte etwas freundlicher sieht es noch
an der küste und an den alpen aus und
zum nachmittag erreicht das regengebiet
dann auch mehr und mehr den osten auch
die nordseeküste und hier auch langsam
den süden weiterhin name diesen
kräftigen südwestwind dazu und das
stärkste regen wird wahrscheinlich
morgen hier so in der gegend des
sauerlandes fallen ja die aussichten ab
heiligabend wird es dann von norden
kühler schneefallgrenze sinkt an den
feiertagen wird es deutlich kühler sein
- ein bis sechs grad und am freitag wird
es auch noch schneien sonst wird es
etwas freundlicher ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut